for one more thing we only got two
minutes juan you're first
all right so dana good news today i won
an award
i came from tv industries broadcasting
and cable
and multi-channel news group the award
celebrates my work as a journalist in
the front ranks of a more inclusive
television industry
here's julio vacaro giving me the award
via zoom
he is especially respected for his pride
on his ethnic heritage
as a black latino the award is presented
to juan williams
special thanks to you for having an
award to celebrate the people at work
creating a more diverse workforce
in american media
i've been at fox since 97 and since then
so much has changed in the broadcasting
industry as it's become more racially
ethnically and gender diverse part of
the diversity
at fox welcoming different voices so
thanks to all of you viewers for
welcoming me as a contrarian a foil a
voice of reason
thanks to all the folks at broadcasting
and cable news
and multi-channel news i'm truly honored
thanks so much
congrats to you that's really good
that's great congratulations congrats